first of all it's a very complex
artifact so you they're not
um programmed they are grown and you get
these emergent capabilities goals and so
on all sorts of strange things happen so
for all intents and purposes it might be
a god
it wouldn't be a god of the thought a
commonly worshiped by Christians uh
Muslims and Jews because that God is
omnipotent and everlasting and you can't
make it
if he doesn't exist now he doesn't exist
it's not that sort of God
um well could I push back on that tiny
bit um because maybe you could argue
that because it could self-replicate
it's clearly something that exists in
the information sphere rather than the
physical sphere but you might start to
get jumps between the domains so it
might print itself it might recreate it
so after a while it might